this is the way the mandalorian episode
8 made it this far
it's not that far Emma so date I'm
excited to check this out as always as a
playlist of all our reactions here up on
YouTube for the Mandalorian the stream
alongs are all over at our patreon page
as YouTube only allows for 10 minutes
worth of footage so these are the
reaction highlights flowing through
action stream along is over at patreon
along with a bunch of other shows there
as well and the man who has been our
most loyal editor for certain shows Eric
the nerd chronic he does work for people
like aqus on Eamon snow the movie trivia
Schmo down which by the way I'm in the
draft for apparently didn't know that
till yesterday he has his own podcast
forever podcaster found he's a great
human being I love the guy so please go
show your support by giving him a follow
and yeah let's watch this I'm see if
this show sticks the landing I forgot to
mention because it's a long season
finale we are gonna be cutting this up
into part 1 and part 2 so keep a lookout
for that link for the part 2 reaction
might be uploaded at the same time or
might be weighing an hour either way
keep a lookout
you know stop hitting him oh nice nice I
like how you moved like a claymation
what's this one called Redemption the
raid full circle
Oh aim proof weapon so what does that
prove
I haven't heard that name spoken since I
was a child oh I was not born on
Mandalore sure Mandalorian Mandalorian
isn't a race backstory
damn danger Will Robinson
Kapaa Quarry music other
[Music]
do you think the mandos of today are
gonna do the same thing for the child
queal
oh I still doesn't know nothing they
might have damn belief chicken I think
he's gonna bring hell awesome awesome
[Laughter]
oh oh my god yo I gotta get a nurse like
this oh damn it look at him oh oh
very
hell yeah yeah oh damn first they could
have some gore but this is pretty sweet
yeah
hey the force of an explosion and
something you don't see every day in an
action scenario nice no oh oh no
oh wow here's the one who can maybe
shoot baby you're a life horse heal him
[Music]
Oh
[Laughter]
promise me you'll breathe you have my
word
I need to remove your helmet if I have
to say but I swore a creep please a
droid it's a Pedro Pascal central
processing unit
you mean my brain brain that was a joke
we could be told dicks and put him into
thumbnail yeah
part one is complete
you